[Music]
moving towards a greener europe means
industries will need to adapt
energy from coal and oil will need to be
gradually replaced by green alternatives
like solar and hydrogen
technology will also play a vital role
meps want more investment in research
and development in pharmaceuticals and
digital technology
support for the transition to climate
neutrality was laid out in the new
eu industrial strategy but that was
before the covet-19 pandemic
in particular
in response to the impact of the
pandemic meps are demanding that the
commission revise its strategy
first parliament wants to help
businesses overcome the crisis
whilst saving jobs and enterprises and
then support them
through the digital and green
transitions
meps want to make sure vulnerable small
and medium-sized businesses are
protected
parliament is calling for a socially
just transition for the industrial
sector
by investing in research and new
technologies and re-skilling workers for
jobs of the future